[Music]
russian state tv can provide a window
into the kremlin the networks are tasked
with telling vladimir putin's preferred
version of events but what's perhaps
most remarkable about their coverage
these days is what they're not talking
about i don't perceive a lot of
war preparations not in the rhetoric on
state tv this canadian ukrainian
journalist has lived in russia for 35
years he remembers the warmongering
prior to russia's invasion of georgia in
2008 an annexation of crimea in 2014.
back then russian tv screens were
dominated by images of violent
ukrainians overthrowing their
pro-russian government
but fred weir says this time is
different the tone in state tv is the
hope for peace
i i just don't
see
the the
warmongering that is imputed to to
russia there's virtually nothing about
the military maneuvers and buildups much
of the coverage has focused instead on
diplomacy on putin the great statesman
forcing the americans to the table
in that situation the russian regime can
present itself as
a strong international power as a power
that wants peace but is ready to defend
itself rasmus nilsson says that's likely
due to russia's national mood opinion
polls show ordinary russians do not want
war with ukraine
this independent russian pollster says
that russians are completely opposed to
war they want a diplomatic solution but
they also believe that the west will
stop at nothing to push keeve to attack
russian separatists in eastern ukraine
that belief is fueled in part by
headlines like these claiming without
evidence that keeve and nato plan to
attack russian-speaking communities in
eastern ukraine analysts warn this
propaganda is designed to convince
russians that the kremlin has no choice
but to intervene in ukraine it the
classic classic false flag that we're
moving now because they are preparing an
attack
and to save our fellow russians from
ukrainian aggression we have no other
alternative
but to but but to do this a potential
russian military invasion of eastern
ukraine being sold as a humanitarian
rescue mission to defend a
russian-speaking population against
attacks from the west
jeff semple global news